"Every lie tell incurs a debt to the truth.
Sooner or later that debt is paid."
The central theme of HBO's dramatic miniseries Chernobyl revolves around how lies can lead to disaster.
How the way we craft stories
about what really happened can cause harm.
This however presents an ironic challenge
when creating a dramatization of real events.
Dramatic narrative by its nature requires modification and simplification of what actually happened.
So how do you tell a story like
this in a way that isn't hypocritical?
Step the series takes to avoid
hypocrisy is the creator's attention to visual detail.
Small details about how things appeared
may sometimes seem inconsequential.
But the series has an outstanding dedication
to portraying these details accurately
and I think it matters.
"Because of the nature of the working area you
will each have no more than 90 seconds.
Some of it is in blocks weighing approximately 40 to 50 kilograms. They all must be thrown over the edge here.
Watch your comrades moving fast from this opening, then turning to the left, and entering the workspace here.
Take care not to stumble.
Do you understand your mission as I have described it?
["Yes, Comrade General."]
These are the most important
90 seconds of your lives."
The documentary footage I'm showing
as a comparison here was often used
for reference in designing
costumes, buildings, sets, etc.
Most of what is changed about the story is shifting things on the timeline or condensing information
or characters in a way that is necessary
to tell the story in only five episodes.
"Above all, while on the roof, throw your debris over the rail. Do not look over the rail. Is that clear?
Very well. On my mark. Ready.
Go."
Seeing the show and reality side-by-side
makes it obvious how understated
the show's approach to the story is.
There would have been many opportunities to try to make events look and feel more dramatic
but it wasn't necessary and I think it pays off.
The significance of getting visual details
like this rail is that each moment of the show
is true to the experience of those who were there.
Even when those moments might be shifted
in time or context for the sake of the narrative.
"One of the atomic reactors at the
Chernobyl Atomic Power plant in the city of..."
[Speaking in Russian]
[Creator of HBO's Chernobyl]
"I was always aware that I was telling a story that meant
an enormous amount to the people that lived through it.
[Creator of HBO's Chernobyl]
There are people alive today,
thousands tens of thousands people alive today
[Creator of HBO's Chernobyl]
who have lost people they love because of Chernobyl
whose lives have been shortened because of Chernobyl
[Creator of HBO's Chernobyl]
there are people walking a lot of people walking around
without a thyroid because of Chernobyl.
[Creator of HBO's Chernobyl]
And it was important for me to tell that story accurately.
Our production designer, Luke Hull,
[Creator of HBO's Chernobyl]
worked very closely with our costume designer
Odile Dicks-Meraux.
[Creator of HBO's Chernobyl]
We just became obsessed with
showing things as they were."
Most docudramas leave it to the viewer to
figure out what events and characters were changed.
HBO's Chernobyl interesting link gives
you the tools to learn these things.
The companion podcast covers much
of what was modified and why.
[Creator of HBO's Chernobyl]
"Of those, many wonderful reasons to do this
the one that was most important to me from the jump
[Creator of HBO's Chernobyl]
was a chance to set the record straight about
what we do that is very accurate to history
[Creator of HBO's Chernobyl]
what we do that is a little bit sideways to it
and what we do to compress or change."
It's an interesting acknowledgement by the creators of the show of the way the meta discussion
and experience of watching a show about
true events is important to the story.
And being transparent and talking about these things and the process of adapting reality to narrative
is commendable. It sets an interesting
new standard for films and TV of this genre.
"The real danger is that of we hear enough lies,
then we no longer recognizes the truth at all."
"What can we do then?"
"What else is left but to abandon even the hope
of truth and content ourselves instead
with stories?"
A while ago, I made a video similar to this one. Comparing the Oliver Stone's movie, Snowden,
to actual footage from the documentary Citizenfour
Right now on Mubi you can watch Citizenfour
and it's a great documentary that I highly recommand.
Go to "Mubi.com/thomasflight" to get access to a free trial of Mubi's excellent hand curated library.
They have 30 films at a time every day one is added and one is taken away and I love that on the site you
can see reviews from other users reviews from critics and Mubi's justification for why they chose this film.
It's a great way to find new
and interesting things to watch.
Go watch citizen 4 if you haven't for free when you sign up for your 30-day free trial at Mubi.com/thomasflight
Mubi.com/thomasflight
Thank you so much for watching. I hope you enjoyed this video special. Thank you to my patrons go to
Patreon.com/thomasflight to find out
how you can get access to bonus videos,
merch, a podcast, a discord channel and more.